I want to say now, ahead of time: when
you're watching this video, please do not
race off and say "First". The idea is you
get on and you say: "First - and the answer
to the question in the video is this.
This is it!" OK -  so let's get there, let's
pose the question. The reason for coming
in on book codes is that they are a particularly
accessible and - y'know -  "easy to visit",
application of checksum technology.
That's what it comes down to. The classic
ISBN-10 . d!0-digits long but that
10th digit is a weighted checksum of
all of the digits that have occurred
previously. And in the course of working
out let's say: "What is the checksum digit?"
I mean, last time, when we introduced
these, we went for the hard stuff first. I
regarded the checksum digit as been
correct. But, if you remember, we damaged
one [digit] in the middle.
Let's do a straightforward one this time
and convinced ourselves that it does still
work. And work out later after that, what
might go wrong. And would it work for
bases of calculation that are different
from 11. Because if you remember it's
effectively [that] we're taking things modulo 11.
In terms of doing another one I'm
going to work out the checksum with you. And
then I'm going to challenge you to get
out there and find out what this book is.
Let me say to you I'm going to consider
this ISBN [points at written-out checksum]
The first nine digits it's:
"0 201 07981 c".  And I [have]
put a "c" at the end to denote that the
checksum digit has still to be
calculated. Those of you have seen the
previous video on this topic will be
very familiar with this. Iif you're not,
see if you can follow it, and if you
can't follow it then go back and pull
down the previous video to start off with.
Every one of these digits in an
ISBN has a weighting, starting at one from
the left the second digit has a weighting
of 2; the 3rd digit a weighting of 3 and so on.
All the way up to a weighting of 9.
But the checksum digit is the one that
checks out all the rest when you've done
this simple addition and multiplication
some modulo 11. So, if you remember, it
goes like this: I calculate the checksum
digit, I was saying, by weighted multiply and
addition. 1*0  + 2*2 +  3*0
+ 4*1 ... and so on ...  + 0*5
+ 7*6  + 9*7
+ 8*8 + 9*1 + the
checksum digit, c*10, because that's
in the tenth position on the right. Skip!
[to written out version]
I did all this last night I worked it out!
What's the answer to all of this? It's
that the equation you have to solve is
186 + 10*c  - that's what it all comes
down to = has got to be equal to 0.
Remembering what we did in high-school
algebra, rearranging equations, it's
easy so far, you say: "OK keep the 10c
on the left hand side move the 186 to
the other side. So it's 10*c = -186
So, again, using Sean's clocks
method, that he did last time, he actually
showed you a way of working out what a
negative number is modulo a certain base
And keep reminding yourselfso - it's modulo 11.
Another simple way to describe the
algorithm for coping with negative
results like this is to say: "Keep adding
multiples of 11 until it goes positive"
That's one of the ways I remind myself
how to do it. If you want to make that
go positive using multiples of 11? Well, I
would point out to you just off the top
of my head, that 11*17 is 187. And 187
is one more than 186. So if you have
-186 + 187 that comes out to being + 1.
You end up with the fact
that -186, let's use "math chat", is:
" ...  congruent to 1 modulo 11".  OK, so if
in doubt keep adding the +11
multiples until it goes positive and
then you'll have your answer.  10c
therefore is now equal to 1 modulo 11.
So 'c' therefore - bring the 10 under and
divide is 1/10 modulo 11. What we did
last time, we're revising it by doing it
again this time, is we say: "Ah! we have to
find inverses. Now at this stage - we did
this for the first time in the previous
video - I've written out the table of
inverses modulo 11. Well 1 is obviously
a remainder of 1. If you want the inverse
of 2 what do you have to do?  You have to
find a multiple of that that makes it be
one more than a multiple of 11. So 6
2s are 12 but 11s into 12 goes once remainder
1. So, in other words, the key multiplier
is 6 that turns our 2 into a 12
remainder 1. And again with a 3 it's
different. {For]  four you would need 4*3s are 12 [which]
is 1*11 remainder 1. So here, then, on this
bottom row are all of the inverses for 1
2 3 4 up to 10. And, as you can see, the
inverse of 10 is 10. It's so-called "self
inverse".  So,  our 1/10th  here gives you
an answer of 10. So we see we've been trying
to work out the checksum digit. It is 10.
This poses us a problem, actually, because
10 looks like two digits doesn't it?
It looks like one zero but it isn't. It's 10.
And immediately, as a computer scientist,
if I had been on the ISBN committee,
I might have jumped up and down in
the 60s, 70s, whenever it wasn't saying: "Look
we have a problem here. Because we're doing
modulo 11 we will end up, occasionally,
with remainders of 10. How do we
represent them? My friends at IBM have
the perfect answer and they've built in
future-proofing by inventing hexadecimal
[notation] which goes all the way up to remainder 16
And they've just used ABCDEF  [for digits from 10 upwards]
yeah I migh thave been tempted to say: "Why not use 'A' ?"
I don't know. I think
I'd have been laughed out of the room
because, of course, ISBNS were
developed, really, by people who were
booksellers, publishers, librarians and as
far as they're concerned it's a literary
background, not a computer science
background. And I bet you somebody said
"Let's use Roman numerals because [then] X is 10".
What does this lead us on to ?
Well, without wanting to get too mathematical,
what it's led us into realizing is that
remainders are important. And the whole
of our adventure that we are beginning today
is all about remainders. Because when it
gets into more advanced coding
theory - which is what you all say you
want me to do, you have only yourselves
to blame! - it's all down to remainders. And we've
got to get very comfortable with
remainders and multiplicative inverses.
Which we've done on the ISBN example. In
mathematical terminology, then, you would
say: "Oh! consider a set of integers Z_n.
What is Z_11?"
Well Z_11 is, basically, ISBNs. The
rules say if you call it Z_11 then it
means all the integers from 0 up to
n - 1. So it's from 0 to 10. Fine,
that's exactly what we've been doing! The
question is, for any given n, I mean you
could have Z_3, Z_4, Z_11, Z_17,
Z_whatever, can you turn it into
something that works? And you would get
one of these inverses, that we had to do
in solving our equation? And the answer,
the short answer, is: "Yes you can as long
as it's [the subscript is] prime. And I want to
just try and convince you about that. What we found in
doing the example was, basically, !0*c =1
{Therefore] c = 1 / 10. So what
that's saying to us is: if you want to
divide by n it's the same as multiplying
by 1 over n, and [thus] if we know how to do
multiples of things we know how to do
division, so long as it's possible to invert
to form the reciprocal of any number in
that field. But if you ever stumble
across something where, for one reason or
another, you can't find an inverse, then
you really are scuppered. This [points at list of
inverses] makes Z be a finite field, because it allows
division. If you get a set of numbers for
a certain Z_n,  or whatever, where you
can't find the inverse then it becomes a
mere ring - not a field (... hope I've got
that right mathematicians ?!). But, yes, so in
general then the set of infinite
integers all good all the way to infinity
there'll be quite a lot where you cannot find
an [integer] inverse. So, in general, arbitrary sets
of 0 to positive integers form rings, not
fields. but the special case where with
the arithmetic we know they form
fields is when they [the number bases] are prime.
What I'm saying here, then, is this: divide is vital!
If it is absent - but the other three:  + - *
are OK then, for that
particular choice of n  - 'p' say -  then you
could say, well Z_p is a  ring. But it's
not a field. All of the prime numbers if
they feature in this Z_m, if m is a
prime it will work. It will have a
multiplicative inverse. You will be able
to divide. And there is no problem. Now I
want to try and convince you about this,
and say it's not just a one-off freak, by
first of all doing a multiply and [an]
addition table for 3.  We all agree
3 is a small odd number. It happens
to be a prime as well. And then you will
say: "Ah! but show us where it goes wrong then!"
This is all about finding inverses.
And if we're using, shall we say, a system
based on 3, rather than 11, then
we know that 3 is prime - it's the
smallest odd prime because 1 doesn't
count remember - computer scientists, you
might think of 1 as being prime but all
that's heresy in mathematics!  1 is special!
OK, on this diagram here ...  Here I
am tackling Z_3. Here's our first foray into
the way you should do things systematically.
It's to say:  well if Z-3 is going to
form one of these fields, finite fields,
where everything wraps round and all the
remainders work, you need always to do
two things: you need to construct an
addition table and a multiplication table.
Let's do the addition table first
and we'll be just using ordinary decimal
arithmetic like we do with ISBN but occasionally
I'll be saying: "Ah! but that's modulo 3,
whereas previously it was modulo 11. And
we have to do a division and get a remainder.
0, 1, 2 there, 0, 1, 2 there
Here we go, look,  0 + 0 is 0,
0 + 1 is 1.  0 + 2 is 2.  Come to the
second row. 1 + 0 is 1.  1 + 1 is 2.
1 + 2 is 3. But we're working modulo 3
now.  3 modulo 3 is 0. 2: 2 + 0 is 2.
2 + 1 is 3. Ah! but it's modulo 3 so
there's a 0.  2 + 2 is 4, but divide
that by 3 and it goes once, remainder 1
So here we are look 0 1 2;  1 2 0;
2 0 1. And here, another wonderful
buzz phrase for you, is that that
addition table shows you that every one of
your possible remainders, 0 1 and 2. In every row
there is a 0 entry. And that 0 entry is
called the "additive inverse". And what it
is saying is 1 plus 2 is 3, but because
it's modulo 3 that's a remainder of 0.
So, in other words, 2 in this field is
behaving like -1, because 1 +  -1
cancels out to 0. So, remember,
when you're doing additions in a finite
field you should be looking at your table
saying: "Is there a 0 on every row? Have I
got an additive inverse?" Because you've
absolutely got to have that, OK? And it's
passed all the tests so far. There are
additive inverses for everything. And it
relates the modulo business to
negative numbers, and everything, as we've  now
discovered. OK, here's the somewhat
harder one you have to construct - for
everything you intend to use in your
codes. You have to construct a multiply
table as well, and show it works. 0 * 0 = 0
0 * 1 is 0.
Anything times 0 is 0. So you get a
row of 0s at the top - that's
absolutely common. I did do a video here,
foreshadowing this, ages ago,  involving
Reed-Muller codes. And I said there you
will always get a row of 0s
possibility for one of your codewords.
It's called the zero vector and we're
getting it here as well. So don't get
worried by that. What about the second
row. 1 * 0 = 0;  1* 1 is 1;  1 * 2 = 2,
just using ordinary multiplication.
No problem. Two 0s are  0;  two 1s are 2;
Two 2s are 4, which goes once remainder 1.
What do we look for in the multiply table?  What
we look for in the multiply table is the
1s entries. And they must be there, in
every non-zero row. You must have 1s - just
one 1, you know and all that. OK, now, I
hope I've got enough space. I just love
saying this word - this is the
'multiplicative inverse'. That's a way then
of forming a table of inverses - by
methods other than just chatting to
Sean and saying: "Oh! it must be such and such",
is [to] write down your multiply table,
look for all your 1s, they've got to be
there. And those are the multiplicative
inverses of those particular numbers.
>> Sean: So, wherever we find a 1 in that table the
things either side of it will be the inverse of
each other?
>> DFB: Yes the column head and the row head.
The trouble is this is easy-peasy.
They're both self-inverse one inverts to the other.
>> Sean: Buto, if we'd done a table for 11 ...
>> DFB: You'd find it dotted with 1s,
all over, and if you'd picked out the row and
column intersection for all those 1s
it would have given us the linear table
I wrote
on the previous slide. Clearly then Z_3 is
a prime field. It's got a multiplicative
inverse, in every row which isn't the
zero row. A set of inverses can be found
by looking into the multiply table,
picking them out, reading off the column
head andn the row. And there you are: that
inverts to that; that's [the] inverse of that.
All right then. So, what would - what could -
possibly go wrong in Z_4 ?
We're motoring! It cannot go wrong! Oh! yes it can ...
OK, here we go folks, this is Z_4, is
Z_4 a field? Is it a ring?
Let's find out. We've got the luxury again
of just using ordinary decimal
multipliers with remainders, that we're
familiar with. So I won't go through it
in great detail. You know how this works now.
Let's take the 3 row [in the addition table] as an
example:  3 + 0 is 3;  3 + 1 is 4;
Right? But remember we're working modulo 4 now.
4 modulo 4 is 0; 3 + 2 is 5; but
5 modulo 4 is 1;  3 + 3 is 6; 6 modulo 4 is 2.
So we complete the addition table
And we look through it and we say:
on every row there must be a 0 because
that's forming the additive inverse and
enabling you to cope with negative
integers in this field. Perfect, no problem.
Multiply. let's try multiply on Z_4.
what happens just like it did for 3 is
that 0 times anything is 0 so
you'll get a zero vector of four 0s. And [then]
you look at 1 and you say: "All right, here
I go: 1 * 0 = 0;  1 * 1 = 1;
1 * 2 = 2;  1 * 3 = 3.  It's easy peasy!
Now let's come on to 2.  2 * 0 = 0;
2 * 1 = 2;  2 * 2 is ... oh heck! 2
2 * 2 = 4 right; But 4 mod 4 = 0;
Fine.  2 * 3 =  6;  6 mod 4 = 2;
That row is a disaster!
And why is it a disaster? It's because
2 is a factor of 4. That's why it
goes wrong on .
It's a bit like sequential cog-wheels on [the Tunny
machine at] Bletchley Park, for those of you who've watched
that video. You cannot have things that
have factors in these alleged things
that work. Now 3 [the third row] behaves itself.
3 * 0 = 0;  3 * 1 = 3;
3 * 2 = 6; 6 mod 4 = 2.
3 * 3 is 9. But 2 * 4 = 8 so that's a
remainder of 1.
But that one bad row scuppers you, because in
order for a thing to be a field you have
got to be able to find a 1 on every single row of your
[multiply] table [that's not the zero rowo] and if you
can't do that, you've had it. What we are
going to find, as we move on into the realms
of higher coding theory, is that Galois
comes to the rescue of computer
scientists. Whereas in the very old  - I
don't know, Egyptian mathematics? -  days or
something. We would have been stuck with the
fact that they knew about primes but they
didn't know about what could be done
with powers of primes. And that is what
almost the entirety of computer-
based coding theory is. It is heavily
dominated by powers of 2. But if you
remember, all the arithmetic has to be
done modulo the number base (or the
*characteristic*),  So when you get to
16 and you think of it as 2 ^ 4, you do not
[in Galois fields] do your arithmetic modulo 16.
You still do it modulo 2, and modulo 2 in the
addition framework means:  our good old
friend 'exclusive or' So, that holds no
perils for us whatsoever, as computer
scientists. The multiply is harder
because as we've seen with 4, just
regarding it has an even number, it goes
wrong on 2. You can't find an inverse.
And if you're going to find one what Galois
says is: "OK, mathematicians, computer
scientist even, listen to me. 'm gonna
have to carefully redefine what "divide"
and "inverse" mean.
Stay with me!